très bien mes chers collègues
se calme on se calme
nous allons commencer
commencer
l'audition je vous rappelle qu'il y aura
à suivre du mois à suivre après la PPR
sur la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
il y aura la PPL sur les sages-femmes
qui va suivre et qui concerne notre
commission donc nous entendons à présent
Monsieur François Braun ministre de la
Santé de la prévention sur le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023
le ministre délégué auprès du ministre
de l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
chargée du compte public monsieur
Gabriel Attal est retenu à l'Assemblée
nationale pour des raisons que chacun
comprendra
et donc il sait
un 49 3 peut-être voilà mais donc il
s'est donc excusé il m'a appelé hier
après-midi
et nous l'entendrons la semaine
prochaine
parce que je lui ai signifié absolument
qu'on entende quand même le ministre des
comptes sociaux avant le pfsl
mais tenez-vous bien ce sera mardi
prochain à 8h30
pardon
ouais c'est ça on verra ça mardi on
verra ça mardi monsieur Beuvry
je comprends que ce créneau n'est pas
idéal mais il serait pour le moins
incongru que nous examinions le PLFSS
sans avoir entendu le mini chargé des
comptes sociaux alors que nous nous
prononcerons également la semaine
prochaine sur la loi de programmation
des finances publiques c'est pour la
vidéo qu'on est dans le noir comme ça
que cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo qui sera retransmise en
direct sur le site du Sénat est
disponible en vidéo à la demande et je
laisse tout de suite la parole à
Monsieur le Ministre
merci
[Musique]
je vais essayer de supplier peut-être à
Gabriel la tanne si vous avez des
questions concernant plus son champ
d'activité
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs
l'examen du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale est toujours un
moment clé de notre démocratie sociale
et solidaire c'est un moment de dialogue
avec nos parlementaires auxquels je suis
vous le savez personnellement très
attaché et je vais essayer aujourd'hui
de ne pas faire de l'absus comme hier
c'est pourquoi je suis heureux de cette
première audition de votre commission
pour vous présenter le premier texte des
finances sociales du quinquennat ce
PLFSS 2023 qui n'est pas un pvss comme
les autres c'est un PLFSS de sortie de
crise après deux ans de pandémie qui a
mis notre pays elle reste du monde au
pied du mur ce PLFSS pose surtout la
première pierre d'une transformation du
système de santé
et traduit les engagements du Président
de la République en la matière
transformation du système de santé vous
le savez que je porte pour transformer
un système actuellement construit sur
l'offre de soins vers un système qui
serait construit pour la réponse aux
besoins de santé de nos concitoyens
c'est enfin un bel effet SS de mesure
concrètes qui investit dans la santé de
tous nos concitoyens qui soutient
résolument notre système de santé et ses
professionnels
ce PLFSS je vous le présente avec
conviction et confiance
c'est d'abord un texte d'investissement
d'ambition pour la santé de nos
concitoyens il s'attaque à trois
priorités l'accélération du virage
préventif plus simplement rendre la
prévention réelle et présente dans notre
société la lutte contre toutes les
inégalités d'accès à la santé et le
soutien de nos hôpitaux
la prévention est la première brique de
ce nouveau système de santé en France
nous sommes en retard en la matière vous
le savez très en retard sur nos voisins
européens un seul exemple les infections
sexuellement transmissibles les IST qui
peuvent être facilement éviter par le
dépistage et la prévention continue à
augmenter principalement chez les jeunes
et je serai amené à y revenir
nous pouvons et nous devons mieux faire
le moment est venu d'inscrire la
prévention dans le quotidien des
Français et de sortir des messages
habituels de culpabilisation en rendant
la prévention aussi attractive que
possible
nous proposons ainsi avec ce texte de
mettre en place des rendez-vous de
prévention qui prendront la forme des
bilans de santé aux âges clés de la vie
25 ans 45 ans 65 ans environ
je souhaite bien entendu que chacun
puisse y avoir accès surtout les publics
les plus éloignés du système de santé
ces consultations seront prises en
charge à 100% par l'Assurance Maladie le
succès de cette mesure tient à deux
enjeux aller chercher nos concitoyens
les plus éloignés du système de santé
aller vers ces concitoyens qui sont les
plus éloignés est évident qu'un patient
qui se réhabitude d'aller voir son
médecin tous les mois la consultation de
promotion est évidente mais justement
aller chercher ceux qui sont loin qui ne
voient pas de médecins c'est un enjeu
majeur et puis proposer si nécessaire
des parcours de santé à l'issue de ces
rendez-vous ça ne doit pas être one shot
si je peux me permettre mais bien le
démarrage d'un parcours de santé
de même le gouvernement s'engage dans ce
PLFSS pour la santé sexuelle la santé
des femmes à travers des mesures de
prévention concrètes je vous parlais des
infections sexuellement transmissibles
nous proposons d'élargir à d'autres
que le VIH le dépistage sans ordonnance
et gratuit pris en charge à 100% pour
les moins de 26 ans
16 prévoit également la délivrance
gratuite de la contraception d'urgence à
toutes les femmes quel que soit leur âge
afin de faire tomber les barrières à
l'accès qui pénalise encore trop d'entre
elles
enfin puisque la vaccination est une
arme de premier plan en manière de
prévention nous proposons d'élargir la
prescription et la réalisation de la
vaccination au pharmacien sage-femme et
infirmiers c'est d'autant plus important
que j'ai dans ces hier vous le savez la
campagne de vaccination pour la grippe
co campagne de vaccination grippe et
covid qui est essentiel dans notre
situation actuelle la France est en
retard sur la vaccination par rapport
aux recommandations de l'OMS qui est de
vacciner 75% de la population contre la
grippe voilà rapidement quelques mots
sur la prévention la deuxième brique
c'est de mener une lutte sans merci
contre toutes les inégalités d'accès à
la santé et principalement contre les
déserts médicaux là aussi plusieurs
mesures concrètes qui pourront améliorer
rapidement la situation en la matière
tout d'abord nous concrétisons dans ce
pffss l'engagement du président de la
République de créer une quatrième année
d'Internet en mesure en médecine
générale cette mesure fait également
l'objet d'une proposition de loi portée
par le président Retailleau qui a été
adopté en première lecture hier au Sénat
je l'ai dit nous proposons son adoption
dans le PLFSS pour 2023 c'est le sens de
l'article 23
cette proposition du gouvernement ne
vise en aucun cas envoyer des internes
en médecine c'est docteur junior faire
des stages dans des territoires pour
boucher les trous sans encadrement elle
vise au contraire à renforcer la
formation nos futurs médecins
généralistes comme il le demande
d'ailleurs pour leur permettre en sortie
de formation d'être plus autonome à même
de gérer un cabinet médical c'est bien
j'insiste la philosophie première de
cette proposition
alors bien sûr pour aider nos
territoires soudains nous souhaitons que
ces internes viennent y effectuer des
stages prioritairement mais cela ne se
fera en aucun cas au prix de la qualité
de leur encadrement
toujours pour inciter les jeunes
professionnels de santé à s'installer
dans les zones sous dotées ce PLFSS vise
concrètement à renforcer l'impact des
aides à l'installation elles sont
complexes elles sont fragmentées elles
sont mal connues des professionnels qui
ne s'y retrouvent plus
nous souhaitons également créer un cadre
plus adapté pour les négociations
conventionnelles qui pourra nous
permettre de mettre en place des
engagements réciproques au service de
français dans tous les territoires
notamment les moins notés ces
engagements dans la logique des droits
et des devoirs de chacun enfin je
souhaite favoriser le maintien en
activité des médecins libéraux proches
de la retraite et pouvoir mieux
mobiliser les médecins retraités actifs
comme cela était le cas pendant la crise
sanitaire c'est un enjeu crucial de leur
présence de leur maintien dans les
territoires
notre troisième brique sera de prendre
soin de notre hôpital que nous soutenons
face à l'inflation qui tape qui frappe
pardon toute l'Europe trop longtemps
l'hôpital et j'en sais quelque chose en
tant que médecin hospitalier a été une
variable d'injustement pour réaliser des
économies au détriment de sa capacité à
réaliser ses missions
ce PLFSS fait le choix volontaire
assumée nécessaire de ne pas faire
porter aux hôpitaux de nouvelles
économies et de les accompagner dans
leur développement comme dans la relance
de leur activité après plus de deux ans
de crise nous prenons ainsi en charge
d'augmentation du point d'indice
l'inflation des charges que connaissent
nos hôpitaux
l'objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance maladie pour l'hôpital
l'ONDA hospitalier progresse ainsi un
niveau de 4,1% soit un effort supérieur
à 100 milliards d'euros en augmentation
de 3,6 milliards par rapport à l'âme
hospitalier 2022 rectifié c'est un
effort ambitieux c'est un choix que je
sais nécessaire et le gage d'un
renforcement de notre système
hospitalier pour aujourd'hui et pour
l'avenir
voilà les priorités de santé auxquelles
les dépensent et les mesures proposées
par splfss vont s'attaquer ce PLFSS
s'est soutient un texte de
responsabilité qui assume le
renforcement de l'efficacité des
dépenses
ma conviction c'est qu'il ne faut pas
seulement dépenser plus mais il faut
aussi bien dépenser ce budget de la
Sécurité sociale porte ainsi des mesures
juste proportionnées afin de préserver
nos comptes sociaux sans faire de
concessions sur la prise en charge des
patients sans remettent en cause le
remboursement bien entendu c'est là
encore primordial pour garantir la
soutenabilité de notre système notre
capacité à continuer à investir dans la
santé nous allons ainsi demander en
responsabilité au secteur de la
radiologie de renforcer la transparence
et l'information sur le coût de leurs
équipements matériels nous allons
également demander une contribution à la
biologie en ouvrant une négociation avec
ce secteur parallèlement à l'engagement
d'une mission pour mieux préparer son
avenir nous allons aussi mieux réguler
la trajectoire très dynamique de
dépenses sur les médicaments tout en
préservant nos capacités d'innovation
d'approvisionnement et de souveraineté
nous travaillons également avec les
complémentaires santé sur de multiples
sensiés dont celui d'un partage
équitable des remboursements dans le
champ de la santé je vous l'ai dit hier
j'assume de définir une cible pour
l'ensemble de ces partenaires et la
négociation s'ouvre avec eux pour
trouver le meilleur chemin pour arriver
à cette cible enfin nous redoublons
d'efforts dans la lutte contre ceux qui
ne jouent pas de jeu de la solidarité le
PLFSS prévoit des mesures concrètes pour
lutter contre tous les types d'abus et
de fraude
en effet nitif ce PLFSS c'est un texte
équilibré ambitieux avec un nom d'âme
dynamique le tout au service de la santé
de nos concitoyens nos dames que je vous
présente traduit les priorités
politiques que je viens d'exposer ces
deux dernières années nous avons fait le
choix d'un investissement courageux à la
fois pour préserver l'activité de notre
pays et la santé de nos concitoyens je
poste notamment au soutien massif
mobilisé pour répondre à la crise
sanitaire avec près de 50 milliards
d'euros déployés du côté de la sécurité
sociale les effets de cet investissement
comment ça se faire sentir une étude
internationale qui sort ces jours-ci
montrera que contrairement aux autres
pays industrialisés le taux de pauvreté
n'a pas augmenté en France à l'issue de
la crise covid
je pense aussi aux engagements durables
du Ségur de la santé tant dans le champ
des rémunérations et des investissements
à hauteur de 19 milliards d'euros nous
continuons avec ce PLFSS dans cette voie
exigeante nécessaire ainsi pour 2023 il
est proposé un niveau élevé à plus 3,7%
hors des pensées
à le faire pour la santé de nos
concitoyens en ville comme à l'hôpital
en parallèle est maintenant que la
tempête semble dernière nous il nous
faut réviser en responsabilité de
redressement des comptes sociaux
cet effort je dirais que force ne sera
pas par des coupes budgétaires sur le
dos de la santé de nos concitoyens se
redressement sera par un investissement
durable dans nos priorités à long terme
nous réduirons nos dépenses en les
rendant moins nécessaires par la
prévention et plus efficace par le
renforcement de la qualité de la
pertinence de notre système de santé en
se concentrant je le disais sur la
réponse aux besoins et non plus sur la
mise en place d'une offre c'est tout ce
que nous commençons à faire avec ce
PLFSS pour 2023
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs comme vous le voyez ce PLFSS
c'est un texte de détermination et
d'engagement c'est aussi je le dis
clairement un texte qui n'épuise pas
toutes les réponses que nous devons à
nos concitoyens et nous soignants ces
réponses ont vocation à être complétées
par les négociations conventionnelles
qui vont démarrer par les propositions
issues de la concertation des partis
prenantes dans le cadre du Conseil
national le refondation de la santé que
j'ai lancé il y a 15 jours en somme ce
PLFSS s'écrit une première page une page
importante il n'achève pas l'histoire
nous savons tous il n'y a pas de
solution miracle mais un ensemble de
solutions au sein d'une boîte à outils
comme nous l'avons fait pour les mesures
de cet été
le reste de cette histoire nous aurons à
l'écrire bien entendu ensemble avec la
seule boussole qui nous réunie je le
sais au delà des clivages partisans
protégés et assuré la santé des
Françaises et des Français je suis bien
entendu à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions
monsieur le ministre je vais passer tout
de suite la parole à Corinne Imbert qui
rapporte la branche maladie et ensuite
Isabelle Doisneau pour le rapport
général merci de la présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour vos propos
introductifs
en tant que rapporteur de la branche
maladie donc permettez-moi de
vous interroger sur la souttabilité
financière de l'assurance maladie
l'autre jour le premier président de la
Cour des comptes à trouver que que le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale était optimiste avec
des recettes estimées très très
dynamiques et des dépenses sous-évaluées
la branche maladie bénéficiant en plus
d'un virement de 2 milliards d'euros de
la branche famille mais je pense que
nous y reviendrons plus tard
le directeur de la CNAM l'année dernière
lui-même estimait que 10 ans de déficits
importants s'annonçait pour la branche
maladie et cette année de manière
surprenante la situation se rétablirait
bien plus vite donc permettez moi de
m'interroger sur les raisons de se
rétablissement faut-il anticiper des
coupes dans les dépenses et si oui
lesquelles alors que l'on sait les
difficultés à réguler les dépenses de
long terme faut-il y voir l'annonce de
nouveaux transferts de ressources à la
cohérence un peu douteuse comme le
remboursement par la knaf de la prise en
charge du congé maternité post-natale
que je viens d'évoquer et enfin dans ce
même point sur les contes de l'assurance
maladie je constate que le programme 379
de la mission santé annonça
remboursement de 1,9 milliards d'euros à
l'assurance maladie au titre du plan de
relance européen après un transfert de
TVA revendiqué sur 2021 au même motif
pourtant il y en a aucune trace dans le
PLFSS pouvez-vous nous éclairer sur ce
point
ma deuxième question porte sur la
trajectoire financière au regard du
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques actuellement en débat
le projet prévoit une mise en réserve à
nouveau d'au moins 0,3% des crédits de
long terme on le sait la commission
d'enquête sur l'hôpital la soulignait
l'ONDAM de ville n'est jamais régulée
hospitalier entre guillemets éponge et
dépassement des autres sous objectifs
les plus de 700 millions d'euros de mise
en réserve et vous nous avez dit que
vous ne feriez pas porter de nouvelles
économies aux hôpitaux donc cette mise
en réserve s'ils ne sont pas le fait des
établissements de santé est-ce qu'ils
seront le fait de mécanisme de
régulation et dans ces cas-là comment
seront-elles comment seront-ils mis en
oeuvre et sur quel poste de dépense
une autre question sur si vous le
permettez un constat avant une question
un constat c'est que ce PLFSS ne
contient pas de mesure dédiées à
l'hôpital en tout cas je n'en ai pas
trouvé
aucune ne concerne son financement donc
oui du nouveau modèle de financement qui
devait être engagé avec une dotation
populationnelle alors que
l'expérimentation prévue n'a pas pu être
lancée et qu'elle sera caduque en 2023
et quid de la sortie de la garantie de
financement pour les établissements de
santé alors que les hôpitaux publics
n'ont toujours pas retrouvé leur niveau
d'activité 2019 bien sûr en raison de la
pandémie mais aussi en raison de de
déprogrammation subie faute de personnel
une question très courte sur le
médicament ou allons-nous sur le
médicament je peux pas être plus bref
sur ce sujet là et puis enfin Monsieur
le Ministre une question que vous me
pardonnerez j'espère et qui relève d'un
rappel à la Constitution dans cette
constitution nous avons un article 34
qui prévoit le domaine de la loi et le
Parlement pour la voter or depuis 2 ans
et même si j'ai envie de vous trouver
des excuses parce que c'est votre
premier PLFSS les ministres de la Santé
se permettent de large dérogation
disposition législatives du code de la
sécurité sociale comptez-vous inscrire
au sein de ce texte financier qui est le
PLFSS la validation législative des
prolongations de la garantie de
financement des établissements de santé
et de la prise en charge intégrale des
téléconsultation je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre
présentation alors c'est votre premier
audition pour le premier PLFSS je vais
participer à ce baptême du feu avec
quelques questions alors la première
étant celle-ci le projet loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour 2023 2027 prévoit à partir de 2025
un taux de progression de Londres à 2,7
puis 2,6 comptez-vous tenir cette
modération dans la progression des
dépenses dans un contexte d'inflation
forte et de besoins importants chacun
le sait on a vraiment des besoins dans
le domaine de la santé plus
particulièrement à l'hôpital la question
suivante
cela fait plusieurs années monsieur le
ministre que le gouvernement se sert
dans la poche de l'Assurance Maladie ça
vient d'être dit par ma collègue pour
financer ses agences sanitaires voire
même le ministère de la Santé par fond
de concours sans repasser devant le
Parlement nous avons voulu l'année
passée avec mon collègue Jean-Marie
vallorenberg avec la révision de la loi
organique sur la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale mettre de l'ordre
dans tout cela car la sécurité sociale
ce n'est pas j'avais utilisé ce terme et
je l'utilise encore open bar pour le
gouvernement écart dans une démocratie
l'argent public est dépensé sur
autorisation du Parlement j'en viens
donc à ma question relative à ce pérfs
je constate que l'approvision pour
dépenses liée au covid est annoncé à un
milliard d'euros ce qui paraît optimiste
a été d'ailleurs dit par la Cour des
comptes également quand on sait qu'en
2021 ce sont 7,1 milliard d'euros qui
ont été dépensés rien que pour les tests
je constate surtout que la dotation a
santé publique France est annoncée en
annexe 2 à
211,96 millions d'euros un montant très
précis mais un montant très éloigné de
ce qui figure dans le rapport de la CCSS
sur les charges prévisionnelles de pour
2023 avec un financement de santé
publique France par l'assurance maladie
à hauteur de 616 millions d'euros alors
faut-il comprendre que nous allons
encore une fois avoir une dotation
exceptionnelle complémentaire par
arrêter sitôt la dotation votée en loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
troisième question il semble que à la
suite de la mobilisation des industriels
et de l'intervention de votre collègue
ministre de l'Industrie le gouvernement
déposé lundi à l'Assemblée nationale des
amendements au PLFSS visant à revenir
sur deux des mesures les plus
emblématiques relatives aux médicaments
et relatives surtout à des économies
j'aimerais savoir quelle sera l'impact
financier de ces revirements sur les
finances de l'assurance maladie et
quelle est la moindre économie estimée
enfin monsieur le ministre en tant que
rapporteur général j'ai la charge du
suivi de la CADES je surveille le lait
sur le feu tous les ans or je n'oublie
pas que c'est la cadèse qui porte 13 des
19 milliards d'euros d'investissement à
destination de l'hôpital rien dans ce
PLFSS puisque le gouvernement s'obstine
a considéré que ses dépenses qui sont
censées transiter par la CNAM ne relève
ni de l'ONDAM ni de la branche maladie
donc une question simple combien de
contrats ont été signés sur le
rétablissement des capacités de
financement de ces établissements sur
les investissements structurants en
clair combien d'établissements sont
concernés et selon quel calendrier
verront-ils ces investissements
concrétisés merci
pour Monsieur le Ministre parce qu'on a
une deux trois quatre on a quand même 15
collègues à suivre
je vais essayer de répondre à l'ensemble
des questions qui étaient touffus
alors l'équipe financiers du pour parler
d'équilibre financiers du PLFSS je vous
l'ai dit ce PSS porte une ambition forte
pour la santé avec son tournat ma 3 7
et sous-ondes établissements de santé
étant hausse de 4,1% dans le but
d'absorber l'inflation et la hausse du
point d'indice et également de soutien
des revalorisations dans le secteur
privé non lucratif le sous-amme ville
permet de financement des conventions
avec les médecins libéraux des masseurs
kinésithérapeutes des chirurgiens
dentistes convention qui sont en cours
et qui vont démarrer
l'équilibre vous le savez sur cette
soutenabilité avec
chaque acteur du système qui va
contribuer à sa juste valeur et je
reviendrai sur les différents points
puisqu'ils ont été évoqués 1,1 milliard
sur les produits de santé 250 millions
sur la biologie 150 millions sur la
radiologie 150 millions sur les
organismes complémentaires 200 millions
sur la fraude et 720 millions sur les
actions de maîtrise médicalisée des
dépenses
le dynamisme de cet ondame 2023 dans le
cadre plus réannuel n'est pas un
traitement de choc ponctuel que nous
compenserons par une austérité dans les
années suivantes c'est une logique qui
s'inscrit également dans la l'objectif
de l'engagement de la France vis-à-vis
de l'Europe avec
un déficit inférieur à 3% du pipe pour
2027 et cette ambition concernant
l'ONDAM de refondation et de
transformation s'inscrit donc dans cette
trajectoire plurie annuelle
l'évolution 2024 2025 2026 reste
dynamique permettant d'assumer toujours
de transformement de son système de
santé de s'adapter au vieillissement
démographique de continuer dans l'axe de
la prévention source bien sûr d'économie
et de continuer également dans la
bataille sur la désertification médicale
l'effort particulier portait sur lame
sera renouvelée en 2024 en 2025 à des
chiffres certes moins élevés mais qui
permettront de soutenir les réformes
d'organisation de notre système de santé
et de jouer également sur l'attractivité
des métiers
ce niveau d’odame devrait permettre
également de faire face aux effets de
l'inflation le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques a d'ailleurs considérer les
hypothèses macroéconomiques comme
réalistes comme j'ai pu me en exprimer
devant la Commission des comptes de la
sécurité sociale
nos dames hospitaliers d'une chose la
dame de ville restera également
dynamique en 2024 et 2025 pour porter
les réformes qui sont issues du CNR
santé en particulier des mesures contre
les airs médicaux avec la négociation
vous le savez de la future convention
médicale cette ambition est partagée
avec les acteurs qui participent au
système de santé afin de répartir les
efforts dans une logique comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure de droit et de
devoir
alors concernant la provision 2023 pour
le covid donc bien sûr
nous assurons aussi la prévention dans
le cadre des finances sociales si nous
souhaitons tous laisser le covid
derrière nous il faut quand même
intégrer ce risque dans le modèle actuel
concernant le covid je peux vous donner
les derniers chiffres qui sont je ne
vais pas dire rassurant mais qui sont
moins inquiétants sur ce qui semble le
plus être un rebond de la vague
précédente qu'une nouvelle vague nous
sommes toujours avec le même le même
variant et nous avons sur les derniers
chiffres le fameux R qui est maintenant
approche les 1 qui n'est plus qu'à 1,07
ça veut dire qu'il chute depuis trois
semaines et le taux d'incidence qui
reste stable aux alentours de 550%.000
ce qui veut donc dire que notre société
aussi est nos concitoyens s'habitue avec
le covid et nous espérons bien sûr
forcer sur la vaccination et cette
double vaccination que j'appelle de mes
vœux maintenant pour les personnes les
plus fragiles c'est pourquoi au titre de
la vaccination 600 millions d'euros ont
été provisionnés pour l'année prochaine
et 400 millions au niveau des tests de
dépistage forcément c'est une estimation
c'est une estimation sur les données que
nous avons aujourd'hui sur l'évolution
de la crise du covid la survenue d'un
variant qui pourrait perturber
l'ensemble de ces estimations
malheureusement nous ne pouvons pas
anticiper sur ce sur ce variante
alors concernant les médicaments
alors les médicaments c'est dépenses des
produits de santé je rappelle quand même
les médicaments c'est payé par
l'assurance maladie c'est pas un bien de
consommation comme les autres c'est un
secteur qui spontanément à une
progression de 6% par an dans le cadre
du conseil stratégique des industries de
santé de président de la République
s'est engagé à une progression annuelle
de
2,4%, nous respectons nous avons
respecté dans l'échéance 2018-2021 et
nous respectons dans les années à venir
c'est engagement du Président de la
République nous allons même au-delà nous
allons même au-delà avec une progression
de 2,8% et 800 millions supplémentaires
cette année pour les industries du
médicament
l'essentiel dans les industries du
médicament c'est bien sûr de prendre
toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
l'accès aux produits de santé à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens à tous les
Français de manière équitable sur
l'ensemble du territoire
il y a également des mesures et vous le
savez dans le cadre de France 2030 et
des mesures que nous avons déjà pris
pour garantir l'accès aux médicaments
innovants avec différents axes et
différentes logiques et en particulier
une logique non plus de payer pour voir
mais de voir l'efficacité des
médicaments pour payer c'est-à-dire une
adaptation du financement des
médicaments des médicaments les plus
innovants tout en garantissant bien
entendu les médicaments génériques donc
il n'y a pas d'économie particulière il
y a simplement
une respect des engagements alors pour
autant et vous l'avez dit il y a des
évolutions concernant toutes les mesures
autour du médicament alors ces
évolutions sont de plusieurs types tout
d'abord les mesures de référencement
périodique nous avions initialement
envisagés et pour lesquels dans un
promotant nous proposons un rapport au
Parlement d'ici l'été 2023 rapport au
Parlement pour voir en gros les
bénéfices les risques les avantages les
limites d'un tel dispositif donc nous
donnons un petit peu de temps pour ce
dispositif concernant la clause de
sauvegarde puisque je pense que vous
parlez de la clause de sauvegarde tout à
l'heure
initialement nous voulions éviter
l'effet rabot uniformes de la clause de
sauvegarde et avoir des effets
différents ponctionnés de façon
différente en fonction de laboratoire
mettant sur le marché des produits
excessivement chers tout en garantissant
les fabricants de génériques et en leur
garantissant de pouvoir avoir un taux un
petit peu plus bas comme je le disais
tout à l'heure la stratégie est de fixer
une cible et de discuter ensuite avec
les différentes parties pour arriver à
cette cible c'est ce que nous avons fait
c'est ce que nous continuons à faire
avec les industries du médicament et
dans les discussions
nous avons plutôt validé avec eux au
milieu de proposition bien entendu
bilatérale et puis de co-construction
une modification de la répartition de la
clause de sauvegarde cette modification
de la répartition n'est plus à 100% sur
le chiffre d'affaires mais est proposé à
70% sur le chiffre d'affaires et 30% sur
l'évolution du chiffre d'affaires par
rapport à l'année précédente
il y a donc là un accord qui a trouvé
avec les industries du médicament ce qui
semble plutôt positif
concernant la Cadès retrouver tout ce
que j'ai sur la calesse oui j'ai
celle-là mais j'ai mieux la mienne
la dette sociale
invocation bien sûr à être à être
remboursé pour ne pas faire peser sur
les générations futures le poids des
prestations actuelles
c'est pas vous que je vais la prendre
mais la loi relative à la dette sociale
et à la l'autonomie du set août 2020
surtout permis de créer aide financer la
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
et aussi le transfert de la dette bien
sûr de la sécurité sociale à la Cadès à
hauteur de 136 milliards d'euros
reprenant ainsi le déficit cumulé depuis
2020 mais également un tiers de la dette
hospitalière déficit pliés bien entendu
à la crise sanitaire cette reprise de
dette a été la reprise de dette a été
immédiatement mise en œuvre avec 20
milliards en 2020 40 milliards en 2021
40 milliards que l'on poursuit en 2022
en 2023 il n'y a pas de transfert
supplémentaire
et comme vous pouvez le voir dans
l'article 13 un de ce PLFSS l'objectif
d'amortissement de la dette sociale par
Cadès est fixé à 17,7 milliards d'euros
qu'ils auront bien sûr à placer sur sur
les marchés
pour revenir je sais pas si utile mais
pour revenir sur
sur le transfert de dettes initial comme
je vous le disais c'est 31 milliards au
titre des déficitants antérieures à 2020
92 milliards au titre des vestites
futures 2020-2023 et 13 milliards de
dettes hospitalières afin de faire face
à cette nouvelle reprise l'horizon
d'amortissement de la Cadès vous l'avez
vu et prolongée jusqu'à 2033
la réforme du financement ah oui la
réforme du financement et vous avez
évoqué le financement populationnel
sujet que je connais bien puisque la
seule activité actuellement dans
l'hôpital qui répond à ce type de
financement et l'activité des le
financement des services d'urgence qui
lui est passé et qui se compose non plus
uniquement d'un financement d'activités
réalisées un financement à l'acte mais
un financement populationnel pour la
majorité avec une part de financement à
l'acte et avec une part de financement à
la qualité et à la pertinence cet
événement
le point vers lequel nous voulons aller
de façon plus globale même si des
financements sont en train d'être
discutés également pour deux branches
particulières qui sont la psychiatrie
comme vous le savez et également le SSR
concernant la psychiatrie nous sommes en
train de là aussi de discuter avec les
différents partenaires pour voir comment
pour le mieux mettre en place cette
énorme nous faisons actuellement le
point à l'issue de cette crise sanitaire
nous reviendrons rapidement pour vous
dire nous en sommes de ces deux
financements et en particulier des
évolutions sur le financement global non
seulement de l'hôpital mais de notre
système de santé qui est un des enjeux
que je veux conduire en parallèle du CNR
territorial national il y a deux groupes
de travail qui vont se mettre en place
avant la fin de l'année avec des
échéances un peu plus lointaines vues de
la complexité du dispositif 1 sur la
gouvernance du système de santé de façon
globale et un autre sur le financement
de notre système de santé je pense qu'il
est temps de tout mettre sur la table
peut-être qu'on reviendra un mode de
financement identique mais en tout cas
il y a plusieurs idées qui est
nécessaire d'explorer
concernant la garantie de financement
j'arrêterai peut-être là quand il
financement prendra fin au 1er janvier
2023 sommes en train de voir quel
dispositif suivant de permettrait de
soutenir les établissements qui sont en
fragilité mais nous gageons sur la
reprise d'activités de ces
établissements nous voyons bien qu'il y
a une perte d'activités dans ces années
covid et les objectifs raisonnables de
reprises d'activité nous permettent
d'envisager le couvrement finalement de
cette garantie de financement pour
l'année 2023
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors nous
avons plusieurs collègues 15
et je vous propose d'en prendre par
groupe de 5 c'est les questions sont
consistes et pas trop longues et pas
trop nombreuses Catherine procacia
Marie-Pierre Richer je signe guidez
merci madame la Présidente vous avez
parlé de prévention monsieur le ministre
et je vois qu'à l'article 8 vous créez
dans le pdfss une catégorie fiscale
spécifique pour le tabac à chauffer
alors mes collègues me connaissent ils
savent que j'ai des idées des suites
dans les idées j'ai donc interrogé
j'avais interrogé votre prédécesseur
sur l'évaluation des substituts au tabac
il y a 15 millions de personnes qui
fument et quand on interroge
quelques-uns pas les 15 millions il y en
a beaucoup qui ne veulent pas s'arrêter
de fumer donc ce que j'avais demandé à
peu près et que je vous demande c'est de
savoir où en sont les évaluations sur
les substituts au tabac telles que le
tabac chauffer puisque alors pour mes
collègues qui ne suivent pas la
différence c'est que le tabac est
chauffé dans un appareil électronique
mais il n'y a pas de combustion alors
qu'avec une cigarette il y a une
combustion il y a bien du tabac dans les
deux mais il y a pas du tout le même
phénomène le Haut Conseil de la santé
publique avait appelé à étudier
l'alternative l'OMS aussi
et la seule étude qui existe c'est celle
de l'Institut Pasteur en 2020
qui qui dit qu'il faut qu'il faut
démontrer sa démontrerait qu'il est
moine nocif mais sans aller plus loin
donc moi je ne reviens pas excusez moi
pour l'aspect financier je ne reviens
pas sur la taxation mais je reviens sur
l'évaluation
est-ce que dans le programme national de
lutte contre le tabac que vous allez
relancer est-ce qu'il va enfin y avoir
une évaluation scientifique parce que si
le tabac a chauffé peut permettre d'être
moins nocif à ceux qui ne peuvent pas
s'empêcher de fumer
est-ce que on va dire aussi c'est aussi
nocif c'est aussi important dans un cas
comme dans l'autre merci Monsieur le
Ministre
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je vous interpeller sur les
médecins qui exercent en PMI si l'on
peut se réjouir que la loi de finance
rectificative 2022 est actée la
conversion de la prime Ségur en
complément de traitement indiciaire pour
l'ensemble des personnels soignants de
PMI et de santé sexuelle je déplore
qu'elle est exclue les médecins y
exerçants ils sont 1700 dans les PMI qui
auront de ce fait une rémunération bien
inférieure à celle d'autres cadres
d'exercices de la médecine salariée
l'augmentation de la mortalité infantile
l'aggravation des maltraitants chez les
nourrissons l'augmentation de la
prévalence des troubles divers sont
notamment là pour nous rappeler que le
repérage médical précoce pour la PMI est
essentielle et vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de prévention je pense que nous
sommes complètement dans le champ de la
prévention de plus les médecins des PMI
partiront d'une double iniquité une
équité entre médecins territoriaux de
PMI lié au caractère aléatoire d'octroi
de la prime Ségur selon la décision de
chaque exécutif des parlementales et
inéquité vis-à-vis des autres personnels
soignants de la PMI qui en bénéficieront
aujourd'hui dans la région Centre Val de
Loire il y a une diminution très rapide
des effectifs de médecine de PMI puisque
nous sommes à moins 24% entre 2010 et
2019 et je suppose qu'il en est de même
pour les autres régions monsieur le
ministre il est indispensable que la
prime Ségure soit convertie de con en
complément de traitement indiciaire pour
l'ensemble des médecins concernés dont
ceux des PMI et de santé sexuelles cette
disposition peut-elle figurer au PLFSS
je vous remercie je suis
donc j'avais deux questions mais je lui
en poserais qu'une pour aller au plus
vite
donc moi c'est au sujet de la cinquième
branche qui a été créé en 2020 donc les
dépenses Soliers au grand âge pour
augmenter de plus de 9 milliards d'euros
d'ici 2030 c'est tout c'est directement
lié au vieillissement des générations du
baby boom selon les projections
démographiques en 2040 15% de population
aura plus de 75 ans moi j'aimerais bien
savoir où nous en sommes dans le
cheminement de cette loi moi je suis
très heureuse de savoir que il y avait
une cinquième branche mais j'ai
l'impression que ça reste au statuko
quand même donc voilà j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a pas grand chose qui en tout
cas qui avance là-dessus et je voudrais
aussi rappeler que certes une politique
de l'autonomie mais qui se réduit pas
qu'augmentage au vieillissement le
collectif handicap évalue entre 10 et 12
milliards d'euros pour le financement
supplémentaire nécessaire à la prise en
compte des besoins des personnes en
situation de handicap donc je voudrais
savoir ça c'est pris en compte aussi en
plus et ensuite serait-il pas
intéressant de contre actualiser les
aesh aujourd'hui on a vraiment besoin
d'aide et ça serait peut-être une façon
d'en avoir un petit peu plus aujourd'hui
et ma deuxième question c'est simplement
les inégalités de traitement liées au
Ségur de la santé mais je vous ai envoyé
un petit courrier donc je suppose que
vous allez me répondre
oui merci Madame le présidente j'aurais
deux questions mais elles seront rapides
la première concerne monsieur le
ministre les IAD e je regrette
d'ailleurs que votre projet de père FSS
n'en parle pas
ce dont un test les nombreux que vont
déposer les députés qui vont travailler
sur le PLFSS à partir de demain et nous
honorons aussi ici sur les bam du Sénat
en effet les iados se battent à juste
titre pour que leur profession soit
intégrées au code de la santé publique
sous le statut d'auxiliaire médicaux en
pratique avancée sur les bancs du Sénat
nous sommes plusieurs à déplorer la non
reconnaissance de leur profession et de
ses spécificités en matière de formation
comme d'autonomie d'exercices laquelle
devrait être assimilée selon le syndicat
national des infirmiers anesthésistes a
de la pratique avancée aussi monsieur le
ministre pour une pourriez-vous nous
dire ce que le gouvernement entend faire
pour améliorer la reconnaissance
critères de la profession diadème leur
formation et leur domaine de compétences
tout en promouvant le développement des
infirmiers en pratique avancées de
médecine d'urgence dont le besoin est
d'ailleurs évident ma deuxième question
concerne l'article 25 du PLFSS voilà une
nouvelle tentative louable pour
combattre le mercenariat de l'intérêt
médical en 2017 un plafond de
rémunération a été fixé à 1170 euros par
tranche de 24 heures or nos hôpitaux en
tension permanente se sont vus imposées
par les intérimaires des niveaux de
rémunération très supérieurs à ce
qu'autorise la loi votre succès de votre
prédécesseur pardonnez-moi avait fait
une tentative en faisant voter la loi
rite
j'allais trop vite excusez-moi je
recommence
je vous rassure ça viendra ça c'est
certain
le plus tard possible je vous le
souhaite je recommence ma question votre
prédécesseur avait fait donc une
tentative en faisant voter la loi rite
pour rendre effectivement cette
rémunération mais avait finalement
reculé devant son application alors
Monsieur le Ministre d'une part
comptez-vous faire respecter la loi en
cadrant les rémunérations des
intérimaires et d'autre part comment
peut-on redonner de l'attractivité aux
carrière au sein de l'hôpital public qui
est en crise cela ne vous aura pas
échappé merci
j'ajouterai aussi ADN et les ebodes un
vrai sujet avec les ébots
Florence lasarade elle ou Florence
je vais
juste revenir sur ce que précédemment
Marie-Pierre Richer a évoqué à propos de
la mortalité infantile on parle de la
santé je suis là Monsieur le Ministre on
a on a
on a on a on a parlé de prévention chez
la femme mais qu'en est-il chez l'enfant
nous sommes passés maintenant au 25e
rang en matière de mortalité infantile
et la cause n'en est pas connu est-ce
que c'est parce qu'il a moins de
spécialistes j'étais pédiatre dans une
vie antérieure est-ce que c'est à cause
des violences
intrafamiliales on n'en sait rien donc
est-ce que vous avez
peut-être sur le projet de l'année
prochaine
un sujet sur la sur la mortalité
infantile mais moi en tant que pédiatre
ça me préoccupe beaucoup pour en revenir
sur les spécialistes la médecine
générale est maintenant une spécialité
mais on sait que les les jeunes médecins
s'installent là où sont les spécialités
médicales autre que la médecine générale
donc est-ce que est-ce que vous pensez
consacrer un volet à la formation des
spécialistes à la rémunération c'était
ma deuxième question troisième question
vous parlez d'une augmentation de 6% du
coût du médicament parent est-ce le prix
du médicament lui-même qui augmente ou
est-ce la consommation qui augmente
quand on parle de prévention que fait-on
pour diminuer la consommation
je pense qu'on est les champions du
monde en matière de psychotrope dont
vous allez parler de la psychiatrie je
pense que c'est un problème également et
la pédopsychiatrie
en fait partie donc
je vais pas parler de l'intérêt de mes
collègues en ont largement parlé
je m'arrête là merci je vous laisse
répondre peut-être vous souhaitez qu'on
continue non ça fait déjà pas mal de
questions
pour recompléter ce qu'a dit Florence la
Sarah dire matin j'étais une table ronde
sur la au Sénat sur la douleur avec la
flamme l'association flamme il y a quand
même un vrai mes usages du médicament
antalgique il y a eu la crise des
opioïdes aux États-Unis bien évidemment
mais je pense qu'il y a vraiment un
travail à faire et un des pharmaciens
nous expliquer qu'il existait maintenant
dans le cas des tests génomiques qui
analyse le profil de chaque personne des
personnes dont on a vu que elles étaient
du fait de leur génome plus ou moins
sensibles voire totalement insensible à
des médicaments antalgiques on parle
beaucoup de ces tests là par rapport au
cancer mais en matière de douleur donc
je pense qu'il y a un gros travail à
faire en fait sur la surconsommation de
médicaments dans des places de formation
ici présent
le médecin qui est presque aussi quand
tu vas chez le pharmacien même sans
prescription tu vas sortir avec des avec
des valises
alors merci pour pour toutes ces
questions alors concernant la prévention
de tabac à chauffer donc problématique
du tabac chauffé vous me dites que 15
millions de de fumeurs ne veulent pas
arrêter
semble-t-il c'est que 2 millions de
fumeurs ont arrêté par l'augmentation du
prix du tabac donc ça c'est quand même
quelque chose d'important le tabac a su
70 000 de nos concitoyens tous les ans
grâce à l'augmentation du prix du tabac
c'est la seule mesure qui avait été
prise nous avons permis à 2 millions de
nos concitoyens d'arrêter de fumer en
cédant effectivement par des substituts
nicotiniques pendant un certain temps
mais l'intérêt de la substitution c'est
d'en sortir malheureusement le tabac
chauffé
a peut-être une image
moins nocive que le tabac normal mais
les études en particulier aux Etats-Unis
montrent que ça amène beaucoup de jeunes
vers la consommation du tabac justement
par le biais de ce tabac chauffé à qui
on donne une image peut-être un peu
moins toxique alors la toxicité du tabac
vous le savez elle est liée
principalement la nicotine en termes
d'accoutumance et puis après plein
d'autres
cochonneries si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
qui sont liés à la combustion mais pas
que
quid d'une évaluation je ne dispose pas
aujourd'hui d'une évaluation nationale
sur les dangers du tabac chauffé il y a
d'autres formes de tabac d'ailleurs
aussi pas que que simplement le tabac
chauffer comme ça mais je retiens cette
idée d'aller vérifier un petit peu tout
ça concernant la problématique du tabac
vous le savez que il y a deux phénomènes
le premier c'est avec l'inflation le
prix du paquet de cigarettes n'étant pas
indexé à l'inflation
paradoxalement il revient moins cher
aujourd'hui d'avoir d'acheter son paquet
de cigarettes que il y a un an donc
c'est quelque chose qui est en
contradiction complète avec l'évolution
du prix du tabac c'est pour ça que nous
voulons remettre le taux d'inflation sur
le prix du tabac donc augmenter un peu
le prix du paquet de cigarettes et puis
il y a les autres formes de tabac qui
n'ont pas du tout les mêmes taxes je
pense en particulier au tabac à rouler
le tabac chauffer et là c'est tout à
fait anormal donc la volonté est de
progressivement arriver à une taxation
identique pour toutes les formes de
tabac qui sont d'une façon générale
toute nocive
concernant les médecins en PMI oui la
problématique des médecins de PMI en
termes de nombre et ça rejoint toute sa
problématique de la prévention mais
comme toutes les spécialités médicales
et particulièrement particulièrement
difficiles et compliquée vous parlez du
Ségur pour les médecins de PMI certes je
vous rappelle simplement que les
médecins hospitaliers n'ont pas
bénéficié non plus du Ségur donc ça
touche pas seulement les médecins de PMI
ça touche la profession médicale dans le
cadre dans le cas du Ségur de la santé
c'est une défectif il va falloir qu'on
puisse qu'on puisse la compenser d'une
façon d'une façon ou d'une autre alors
sur des détails très très précis je suis
obligé d'en référer
son champ au niveau de la PMI mais je
vous rejoins complètement en ce qui
concerne la prévention qui doit être
conduite bien sûr dès l'école de tout ce
qui est PMI dans l'entreprise également
avec la médecine du travail qui est en
déshérence
titre personnel je suis favorable à
l'évolution des spécialités d'IPA vers
des IPA en santé publique de l'enfant
alors est-ce que ça devrait être des ipa
ou est-ce que vous le savez on va
prolonger la formation des QR est-ce que
dans cette prolongation de Pierre il
serait pas plus pertinent dans le
progression de leurs études de mettre un
chant un module sur la santé publique
pour permettre à ces prières
d'intervenir justement en
PMI je serai plus tendance à aller vers
cette vers cette logique qui rejoint
d'ailleurs la problématique des
infirmières spécialisées qui ne sont pas
dans le cadre d'IPA on parle des puères
qui vont évoluer on parle des ibots on
parle effectivement des IAD e alors ce
sont certes des infirmières spécialisées
mais leur formation ne correspond pas à
la formation qu'on demande aux IPA
aujourd'hui puisque la formation des IPA
c'est d'abord une année de tronc commun
sur lequel elles font elles refont une
formation de physiologie d'anatomie une
formation très généraliste c'est un
tronc commun pour toutes les spécialités
d'IPA et c'est ensuite leur deuxième
année qui est une année de
spécialisation pour les IPA qui existent
actuellement vous parlez de l'urgence
effectivement sans études même s'il n'y
a que 7 IPA d'urgence malheureusement
pour l'instant et de toute façon une
façon générale assez peu d'IPA et
insuffisamment d'IPA pour ça que nous
allons faire un effort par rapport par
rapport aux IP alors quelle place vont
trouver ces infirmières spécialisées
c'est vraiment sujet de discussion que
nous allons avoir avec elle certaines
ont un exercice spécialisé mais on peut
pas leur donner statut d'IPA puisque une
IPA par définition par exemple une IPA
qui serait hyper d'urgence si demain
elle veut faire du suivi de pathologie
chronique il suffit qu'elle refasse un
seul une seule année de formation
puisqu'elle a le tronc commun donc voilà
on a une complexité à gérer qui est plus
une complexité réglementaire et
administrative en tout cas reconnaître
leur spécialisation en grade de master
et quelque chose qui est tout à fait
dans la logique
concernant la cinquième branche et le
vieillissement oui bien sûr il y a la
problématique du vieillissement qui
arrive et d'un déséquilibre des comptes
sociales je ne ferai pas ici le
dérapage de dire que sa justifie bien
entendu qu'on travaille également sur
les retraites et sur la progression
d'activité pour équilibrer nos comptes
nos comptes sociaux concernant ces
axes qui sont faits dans le cadre de
l'autonomie du handicap dans le PLFSS il
y a quand même des des axes forts qui
sont mis qui sont mis en place les
recrutements dans les EHPAD l'objectif
50 000 recrutement dans les années dans
les années qui viennent les deux heures
de vie sociale par semaine qui ont été
rajoutées qui sont des mesures fortes
qui se rajoutent aux mesures de la loi
de finances de 2022 en tout cas cette
cinquième branche est indispensable
nécessaire et nous avons des ambitions
fortes en ce qui concerne cette
cinquième branche
le mercenariat et l'intérim
je fais attention de pas faire de lapsus
donc attendez bien la fin de ma phrase
l'intérim
l'intérim est une bonne chose dès lors
que l'intérim répond aux besoins ce
pourquoi il est fait c'est-à-dire
remplacer ponctuellement des congés
malades ou des congés des congés
maternité par exemple moi ce que je
dénonce c'est l'intérim que j'appelle
cannibale c'est-à-dire cet intérim qui
fait monter les prix je l'ai vécu il y a
encore quelques mois ou pour savoir si
quelqu'un sera de garde le lendemain il
attend la veille au soir pour faire
monter les prix c'est inadmissible d'un
point de vue éthique je ne peux pas
accepter qu'un médecin gagne en une nuit
deux fois ce que gagne une infirmière en
un mois
c'est inacceptable donc dans ce
péripétss il y a des mesures contre
l'intérim il y a la mesure en
particulier qui lutte contre l'entrée en
intérim entre guillemets de la fin des
études c'est aussi une mesure de
sécurité de nos concitoyens parce que
l'intérim est un exercice difficile qui
nécessite une adaptation qui nécessite
une expérience que non pas les jeunes
diplômés quelle que soit les professions
de santé fait qu'on a des intérimaires
dans nos hôpitaux qui je suis désolé de
le dire il y en a des très bons mais il
y en a aussi des pas bons donc ça met
encore plus en danger le fonctionnement
de nos hôpitaux en ce qui concerne la
loi que vous avez votée l'année dernière
la loi de modernisation de notre système
de santé par la
par la simplification et là donc un mot
enfin bref la loi risque
concernant cette loi riste je l'ai
annoncé et les mesures de limitation
financière de l'intérim seront
appliquées au printemps de l'année
prochaine pourquoi printemps de l'année
prochaine parce qu'il faut un donner une
date de donner le temps aux
établissements de s'organiser cela va
créer des problèmes c'est évident les
intérimaires vont se mettre en grève ou
refuser de travailler alors on s'est
parfaitement ça va durer un mois donc il
faut que les établissements puissent
anticiper puisque collaborer entre eux
pour anticiper justement cette ce delta
pendant un mois mais nous devons agir et
nous devons agir maintenant il est plus
possible d'attendre sinon on va mettre
on va faire effondrer l'ensemble de
notre système de santé
mortalité infantile oui la cause j'ai
pas d'explication aujourd'hui sur cette
augmentation de mortalité infantile on a
des interrogations aussi sur
sur les problèmes médico-psychologiques
des jeunes enfants vous avez vu les
derniers résultats de l'Observatoire du
suicide qui sont extrêmement alarmants
pour les jeunes filles de 10 à 14 ans
donc là des vraiment des problématiques
que nous sommes en train d'investiguer
vous parlez de l'installation des des
jeunes médecins ils s'installent là où
il y en a d'autres oui mais pas que il
s'installe là où ils peuvent avoir un
exercice plus professionnel donc là
aussi c'est un des engagements de ce
PLFSS quant aux consommations et aux
usages des médicaments oui bien sûr je
vous suis totalement là dessus nous
sommes dans une logique de pertinence et
déficience des traitements c'est tout ce
qu'on appelle la maîtrise médicalisée
des dépenses vous avez vu il y a plus de
700 millions de mémoire sur cette
maîtrise médicalisée des dépenses c'est
un enjeu c'est un enjeu majeur de la
société c'est un enjeu par rapport au
benzodiazépines je sais que hier soir je
n'ai pas vu mais vous avez peut-être lu
le livre maman ne me laisse pas
m'endormir qui est absolument
remarquable téléfilm qui en est sorti
c'est parti est passé hier soir sur la
télévision belge je n'ai pas pu le voir
mais c'est un jeune homme qui meurt
d'une surdosage en base audiazépine et
en opioïde
c'est un véritable problème de santé
publique auquel je vais m'attaquer de
façon ferme
j'ai à peu près le tour de cette
première série
merci Madame
monsieur le ministre j'avais exactement
la même question que notre collègue
Marie-Pierre Richer concernant la PMI je
vous ai entendu dans votre réponse
j'avoue je suis un peu déçu parce que
vous nous placez et vous déplacez la
question sur les puéricultrices et les
IPA certes ça va être une réponse mais
aujourd'hui des médecins de PMI qui sont
en première ligne sur la prévention
quand on vous entend monsieur le
ministre on sait votre intérêt là-dessus
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez leur répondre
concrètement je crois savoir qu'il y a
des négociations avec le Syndicat
national des médecins de PMI en ce
moment et et votre cabinet est-ce que ce
PLFSS peut avoir concrètement une mesure
les concernant et qu'elle piste vous
évoquez autrement que sur le les
propositions de transformation des
professionnels dans ce secteur essentiel
concernant la protection maternelle et
infantile moi j'avais deux autres
questions à vous poser toujours dans le
volet prévention qui donc moi je me
réjouis que vous soyez le ministre de la
santé et de la prévention avec d'autres
collègues ici présente ou pas nous avons
travaillé sur la prévention de l'obésité
du surpoids et je voulais vous poser une
question est-ce que vous pensez pas que
dans il y a une contradiction entre le
message
important indispensable sur le sucre
la possibilité du sucre
une alcool et le fait que maintenant les
titres restaurants vont pouvoir
autoriser le remboursement des
confiseries et de l'alcool est-ce que
vous avez été
concerné en tout casser j'imagine que
non et est-ce que vous avez votre mot à
dire là-dessus parce qu'il y a vraiment
contradiction sur deux messages et de
mesures et puis l'autre sujet de
prévention ça concerne les aidants des
proches malades alcooliques c'est un
sujet dont on parle peu on parle de la
maladie
alcoolique et c'est vrai que c'est un
fléau un fléau pour les conjoints les
enfants la famille en général et ses
proches qui aident sont aussi en
souffrance ils sont même parfois
victimes je pense que un signal un
message de votre part
concernant une sensibilisation à cette
question serait la bienvenue en tout cas
répondre aux collectifs national des
proches des malades alcooliques merci
Monsieur le Ministre Daniel Chassin
ensuite Corinne Ferret et victoire
jasmin merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre
présentation
donc
concernant la prévention concernant la
lutte pour les déserts médicaux
l'ONDAM la responsabilité donc je
poserai deux questions je ferai deux
réflexions tout d'abord sur les
médicaments
vous avez indiqué que vous aviez
co-construit avec laboratoire et
sûrement les pharmacies qui étaient
un petit peu angoissé par ce qui était
annoncé notamment sur les référencement
de médicaments qui ont été traités par
appel d'offres donc ça c'est réglé très
bien concernant l'ONDAM plus de 4%,
c'est bien parce que je voudrais
rappeler que c'était un homme de 2%
entre 2012 et 2017 et seulement
2,5 entre 2017 et 2012 donc 4% on peut
faire éventuellement des investissements
donc je poserai je poserai deux
questions concernant vous avez dit
mobiliser les médecins retraités
vous savez que lorsque on est médecin
retraités bon on est obligé si on a si
on travaille un petit peu d'être inscrit
à la carpe beaucoup ne veulent pas et
s'ils sont uniquement inscrits à
l'URSSAF ils ne peuvent pas dépasser
19000 euros de chiffre d'affaires donc
pas faire beaucoup de remplacement
est-ce que ça pourrait être augmenté et
deuxième question concernant la
quatrième année d'internage j'ai lu La
Tribune donc des des étudiants qui
disent non au territoire perdu par la
République et qu'il ne souhaite pas s'y
installer
mais le projet d'abord ne contraint ne
les contraint pas de de s'installer mais
ils disent c'est une réforme méprisante
alors
je peux comprendre si par exemple il
restait un salaire de 1500 ou 2000 euros
par mois ne faut-il pas négocier avec
rapidement pour leur indiquer que ce
sera pas du tout le cas et que en
quatrième année bien ce sont des
médecins même si ils seront installés
effectivement avec un renforcement de la
formation de l'encadrement et qui ne
mériterait au moins c'est ce que j'avais
dit hier dit consultations par jour 5
jours par semaine
ce qui paraîtrait tout à fait logique
merci alors Monique Lebas
dépassé déjà à la deuxième la présidente
monsieur le ministre je vous parlerai du
Ségur les banni du Ségur les exclus du
Ségur les oubliés du Ségur les
invisibles enfin bon nous recevons de
très nombreuses saisines de la part de
nos administrer qui font part de leur
colère et de leur incompréhension du
fait de ne pas bénéficier du Ségur alors
même qu'ils ont été en première ligne
devenu leur poste durant la crise de la
covid pour répondre aux besoins de la
population au risque de leur santé ce
sont des salariés des établissements
médico-sociaux des professionnels dans
le secteur privé et associatif ou encore
des membres de la fonction hospitalière
publique et cette liste n'est pas
exhaustive il est elle témoigne de leur
démobilisation démobilisation alors que
leur effort n'est pas reconnu et qu'ils
ne sont pas traités pour des raisons qui
leur échappent de la même manière que
leurs collègues la solidarité au sein
des équipes de ces métiers souvent très
durs sont trouvés à moindre riz c'est
par exemple un ouvrier principal
deuxième classe qui m'interroge pour
savoir si le sort de sa catégorie
professionnelle est toujours en cours de
négociation il lui explique travailler
en ESAT et être moniteur d'ateliers en
blanchisserie sur sa fiche de poste et
entend et en tant qu'ouvrier principal
sur son contrat à ce titre il n'a pas
droit au Ségur pourtant dès le début du
covid les travailleurs handicapés ne
travaillant plus ce sont eux les
moniteurs qui ont traité tout le linge
des EHPAD et des hôpitaux en arrivant
dans leur structure c'est par ailleurs
une cadre administrative dans un
institut médico-éducatif relevant de la
convention 66 et accueillant des
autistes sévères elle a 30 ans
d'ancienneté dans la même association
dit être dégoûtée et envisage de quitter
un secteur d'activité qu'elle juge
discriminant après des années de bons et
loyaux services en novembre 2021 les
personnels de la filière soignante des
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
elle attire mon attention sur le dernier
décret en date du 22 avril 2022
conditionné à la négociation de la
convention collective unique étendue
pour la filière socio-éducative des
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
ce décret comporte une fois de plus une
liste incomplète en ce qui concerne les
professionnels principalement dans le
secteur privé et associatif les filières
administratives et logistiques sont
toujours et encore exclus de la prime
Ségur alors qu'elles sont essentielles
au bon fonctionnement des établissements
et ont été présentes depuis le début de
la crise sanitaire les professionnels
investis dans ces filières sont en bas
des grilles sal aujourd'hui il craignent
qu'avec la négociation de la CCE la
prime ne leur soit pas accordée malgré
un contexte d'inflation de plus en plus
difficile à supporter pour les bas
salaires c'est aussi le groupe national
des établissements publics sociaux et
médico-sociaux qui regroupent plus de
700 établissements et services publics
sociaux et médico-sociaux répartis
partout en France qui n'a cessé de
demander l'application du complément de
traitement indiciaire issus du Ségur de
la santé à tous les agents de la
fonction publique hospitalière sans
exception quel que soit leur grade et
quel que soit le statut ou type
d'établissement d'exercice il m'a l'air
totalement sur la crise du recrutement
qui touche tout le secteur il signale
que si la dernière extension du CTI à la
filière des métiers de l'accompagnement
a constitué une indispensable avancée
telle est loin d'être suffisante et
satisfaisante en effet les agents des
filières administratives de direction
technique et logistique demeure encore
exclues dans certains établissements de
l'afph il s'agit des structures du
handicap
non rattaché aux établissements je
confirme de santé ainsi que des
établissements de protection de
l'enfance alors que les agents de cette
même filière ont été revalorisés dans
les hôpitaux et les EHPAD créant une
inégalité de traitement les
fonctionnaires
hospitalières donc face à ces situations
monsieur ministre est-ce que est-ce que
vous prévoyez de prendre encore en
compte toutes ces demandes
merci
Corinne Ferret et Victor jasmin merci
Madame le présidente monsieur le
ministre je souhaitais vous interroger
sur les moyens dédiés aux hôpitaux
particulièrement les hôpitaux publics et
notamment dans la situation à laquelle
ils sont tous confrontés j'ai envie de
dire comme nous tous mais ces
établissements hospitaliers se
confrontés à cette inflation dont vous
avez parlé inflation qui se concrétise
dans leurs dépenses de fonctionnement
mais aussi dans leur budget
d'investissement dépenses de
fonctionnement vous le savez vous l'avez
évoqué ce sont l'augmentation très forte
des prix de l'énergie le chauffage
l'électricité mais aussi le coût de
l'alimentation qui concerne qui va
impacter très directement ces
établissements vous avez évoqué monsieur
le ministre que dans ce PLFSS il y
aurait une prise en charge
de cette inflation que je qualifie
inflation dite de fonctionnement est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
est-ce que l'ONDAM qui
doit être dédié notamment au moyen
attribués à ces établissements on va
donc être en augmentation enfin donc
j'ai évoqué cette inflation sur les
budgets d'investissement bon nombre
d'établissements bénéficier donc
d'investissement conséquent de la part
du gouvernement dans le cadre des
Investissements dit investissement du
Ségur dans mon département le Calvados
c'est le cas pour plusieurs
établissements mais il se trouve
aujourd'hui confronté à cette inflation
constatée sur les coûts des travaux les
coûts de matière première et certains
établissements s'interrogent même sur la
possibilité de maintenir ces projets qui
sont tout à fait essentiels pour leur
établissement et surtout pour les
patients et les territoires donc il y
aura-t-il une compensation
on pourrait dire dans ce belfss pour
permettre à ces établissements de mener
à bien ces investissements sans qu'ils
ne soient obligés de
ponctionner leur propre budget ce qu'il
serait tout à fait dans la capacité de
faire
il y a victoire jasmin
merci Madame merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre je suis très sympa
ce que vous comptez faire justement pour
la santé mentale parce que vous avez
déjà évoqué cette problématique et une
des collègues à également poser une
question qui serait relative à cela mais
mon collègue Jean soleil moi-même nous
avons fait un rapport et le gouvernement
avait lu aussi mis en place au mois de
septembre dernier des assises la santé
mentale pourtant dans les différentes
possibilités que vous avez suggérées et
que vous prévoyez de faire concernant la
prévention je ne vois pas apparaître en
tout cas je n'ai pas entendu ce que vous
comptiez mettre en place pour les
projets territoriaux de santé mentale
notamment pour faire suite au rapport de
ligase pour améliorer les parcours de
proximité parce que le délégué
ministériel à la santé mentale à la
santé mentale et à la psychiatrie avec
un certain nombre de préconisations lors
de notre rapport et pour le moment dans
ce que vous
[Musique]
aussi que tant au niveau national au
niveau de nos différents territoires
d'outre-mer il y a vraiment un gros
problème des problèmes relatifs au cours
et aussi au cours auprès de l'approche
que nous devons faire face notamment et
au dispositif qui doivent être mis en
place par les biologistes que ce soit
dans le privé ou dans les établissements
publics de santé dans la mesure où il
faut des systèmes de backup de plus en
plus pour assurer cette continuité de la
qualité des soins et c'est important
qu'il y ait maintenant avec différents
référentiel qu'il y ait des équipements
capables d'assurer la suppléance donc la
générations alors que au niveau de la
nomenclature c'est un vrai sujet qu'il
faudrait prendre en compte et là
maintenant que vous allez rencontrer les
biologistes il faudrait penser aux
outre-mer ou pour lesquelles en tout cas
il y a de vrais sujets de surco pour le
fonctionnement des laboratoires de
biologie médicale et il faudrait
également voir les coûts les cours je
dis bien les cours il y a des sucres
même au niveau national de tous les
dispositifs médicaux et des réactifs et
des consommables et ma toute dernière
question monsieur le ministre je vais
pas monopoliser la parole mais quand
tout le monde parle en même temps donc
j'ai l'impression excuse-moi Jocelyne je
t'ai écouté avec attention je te
remercie
oui bah parce que j'écoute toujours tout
le monde et la dernière chose c'est que
il s'agit de cure thermale alors j'ai
entendu l'actualité et les culte Hermal
il y a un abonnement qui a remis en
cause et culture même alors moi je pense
qu'il faut il fait activement évaluer et
faire un véritable travail parce qu'il
faut effectivement évaluer ce qui s'est
fait voir ce qu'il y a modifié peut-être
le modèle économique mais et ne pas
prendre en compte et ne pas prendre en
charge et que thermal ce serait
probablement une une erreur là aussi
donc je crois je crois qu'il faudrait
revoir revoir les dispositions qui
permettent justement cette prise en
charge évaluer les différentes
possibilités et les parcours les
personnes qui ont bénéficié pour voir à
quel moment c'est nécessaire de prendre
en charge ou pas mais c'est un vrai
sujet et je crois que arrêter
complètement de prendre en charge ne
permettrait pas en tout cas la
prévention et voulu par vos soins voilà
je je mériterais là je vous remercie
merci
je vous laisse répondre il y a encore 5
questions
on répond peut-être à ça oui oui vous
êtes marqués ensuite ce sera on continue
non
on peut continuer alors on n'est pas le
Savary Colette mélo chanson
très courte
le ministre
de source potentielles d'économie un sur
les bio similaires est-ce que vous
comptez allonger la liste des ceux qui
pourraient être justement rentrés dans
ce cadre là
deuxièmement ce qui concerne les études
médicales est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
puisque vous ne pensez pas qu'il faut
revoir la directive européenne et faire
le les deux premiers cycles en des
études médicales en 5 ans et non pas six
ans justement pour amortir je dirais la
l'année supplémentaire dans le dans le
troisième cycle et réduire d'une année
l'ensemble des études médicales qui
notamment pour les généralistes sont
passés de 7 ans ce que l'on a connu pour
beaucoup à 10 ans prochainement
deuxièmement une question de précision
qu'est-ce que vous pensez et donnez-moi
quelques explications pardon sur ces
possibilités d'un con fonctionnement
sélectif assis sur des critères pouvant
tenir à la densité médicale est-ce que
cela veut dire que la confusion d'hier
entre la concertation et la coercition
n'était pas un lapsus
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je ne vous apprendrai rien en
disant que la présence des
professionnels de santé dans les
territoires est une des préoccupations
les plus importantes des Français
on a conscience que les choses avancent
mais il y a un réel problème concernant
la formation et pas seulement des
professions de santé les professions
médicales mais aussi des professions
paramédicales et médico-sociales il y a
un besoin de de formation et un besoin
de formation au plus près des habitants
il y a des territoires qui sont
complètement dépourvus et je crois que
les jeunes qui sortent de
leur du système scolaire et les
personnes en recherche d'emploi
pourraient
accepter des emplois dans les EHPAD dans
d'autres établissements et ils ne
peuvent pas de formation
voilà il faudrait aller au plus près
dans les territoires la France est un
grand pays où il y a des zones
désertiques il faut pouvoir je dis pas
qu'il faille mettre un centre de
formation dans chaque village de France
c'est bien impossible mais voilà en
mettre davantage délocaliser les
formations en ce qui concerne les
formations universitaires la
délocalisation est aussi favorable pour
pour les pour les personnes qui qui sont
qui sont loin des villes universitaires
mais aussi nous le savons maintenant
les étudiants ceux qui sont formés à un
endroit en principe s'installe donc à
cet endroit donc c'est bon ça alors je
sais que c'est une répétition je
n'apprends rien dire ça en disant ça
mais voilà je voulais le dire à nouveau
parce que il y a une souffrance surtout
dans les milieux médico-sociaux pour les
formations merci
merci Jean-Sol je rappelle que nous
sommes sur le PLFSS
et madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues quelques
interrogations notamment sur votre
objectif de lutter contre la pénurie
médicale nous sommes confrontés sur nos
territoires au-delà des inégalités que
le que l'on peut observer à une
multitude maintenant de personnes qui
viennent voir leurs élus notamment et
qui se retrouvent sans médecin traitant
son médecin de famille puisque sauf
erreur de ma part je crois qu'il y a 6
millions 6 millions en France qui n'ont
pas de médecin traitant soit
11%, que pouvons nous dire à ces
personnes qui qui nous appellent qui
viennent nous voir au sein de nos
permanences et puis et puis qui sont
souvent à la porte de la mairie et qui
sollicite leur mère et leurs élus que
pouvons-nous leur dire est-ce que vous
envisagez d'augmenter le nombre
d'assistants médicaux qui avaient été
porté à un moment donné à quatre mille
et qu'envisagez-vous de faire du stock
des 2400 dossiers que vous avez et qui
n'ont a priori pas été traités par la
dose je crois et le CNG donc j'ai cru
comprendre par votre collègue Madame
Agnès Firmin le Baudot que le turbo
serait mis mais je voulais avoir votre
votre avis là-dessus est-ce que vous
envisagez de booster
excusez-moi parce que
j'écoute moi aussi mes collègues est-ce
que vous envisagez de booster le DMP
après autant de décennies d'inertie
certains jeunes médecins le réclament
aussi et puis j'ai une dernière question
en tout cas une remorque que je voudrais
renforcer la prise de parole de ma
collègue victoire jasmin puisque nous
avons effectivement travaillé sur un
rapport suite à la crise sanitaire sur
l'impact du covid sur la santé et en
particulier des jeunes monsieur le
ministre vous soulignez tout à l'heure
le nombre de décès de ces jeunes qui qui
va en augmentation donc j'ai pas vu
grand chose sur la santé mentale et la
psychiatrie dans ce pdfss est-ce que
vous pouvez nous donner un peu d'espoir
s'il vous plaît merci
merci Madame ma Présidente je voulais
monsieur le ministre commencé par un
constat et constat qui va abonder dans
le sens de la réflexion qui vient d'être
faite par madame la Présidente
comme vos collègues prédécesseurs avec
lesquels j'ai travaillé ils avaient
Bertrand Rosine Bachelot marie-sol
Touraine Agnès Buzy et Olivier Véran
vous faites là vous faites la confusion
entre projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale et loi de santé
relatives à l'organisation de la santé
sur le territoire national et je pense
que quelque part c'est dommageable pour
faire avancer l'organisation
territoriale en particulier de la santé
alors j'ai deux questions à vous poser
monsieur le ministre la première le
gouvernement a déposé à l'Assemblée
nationale une Niasse d'amendement je
pense que même s'il y a un 49,3 étant
donné que ce sont des amendements
gouvernementaux ceux-ci se retrouveront
dans la loi définitive de financement de
la sécurité sociale et parmi ces
amendements vous avez déposé un
amendement concernant
la permanence des soins qui selon
le texte que vous avez écrit un combat
est collectivement à l'ensemble des
établissements ainsi qu'aux professeur
de santé médecins chirurgien-dentiste
infirmière et sage-femme alors deux
questions à ce sujet est-ce que vous
comptez revenir et pour moi ce serait
une bonne chose sur les arrêtés sur les
arrêtés pris par Monsieur Mattei
supprimant l'obligation de de garde pour
les médecins
libéraux en particulier et si les
cliniques privées
entraient dans la permanence de soins
j'espère que seront obligés de le faire
dans le cadre évidemment du tarif
opposable
deuxième question monsieur le ministre
est-ce que vous croyez au parcours de
santé au parcours de soins
beaucoup d'actes médicaux sont
maintenant délégués à d'autres
professionnels de santé que les médecins
alors si oui si vous croyez à ce
parcours de soins comment est-ce que
vous le définissez et qui dans ce
parcours de soins est le pilier de ce
parcours de soins si je vous demande
cette question c'est pour savoir dans le
cadre du pilier de parcours de soins qui
doit-on voir en premier dans le cadre
d'une première intention aux soins
et ensuite Véronique
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
je voudrais vous avoir une petite
précision vous avez annoncé et c'est une
très bonne chose 150 000
employés supplémentaires pour les EHPAD
vous avez parlé de 50 000 mais il y en a
que 3000 qui sont budgétaires dans le
PLFSS donc comment est-ce que vous
comptez arriver au 150000 si on en met
3000 par an
deuxième question j'ai rencontré la
Mutualité Française
qui
propose ou qui a comme idée de faire
financer le grand âge par une par les
assurances quel est votre avis par
rapport à cette à cette question et la
troisième chose j'ai été contactée par
des laboratoires de biologie
indépendants dans mon département pour
lesquels on demande 250 millions
d'économies
or ils ont peur que ça les fragil par
rapport au gros groupe et il
préféreraient qu'au lieu d'avoir une
diminution des actes de base c'est 250
millions soit plutôt reportés sur les
actes qui sont liés au covid
pour lesquels ils ont été
bien
où ils ont une belle augmentation
donc voilà merci Monsieur
le mini j'ai deux questions sur
l'article 22 et l'article 23 donc
l'article 22 qui évoque le
l'actualisation la clarification et
l'harmonisation du des conventionnnement
passant entre l'assurance maladie et les
professionnels de santé j'ai lu quelques
articles est-ce que derrière est-ce que
cet article ne vit enfin qu'est-ce qu'il
vise est-ce qu'on est sur du
conventionnement sélectif ou pas enfin a
priori ce que j'ai lu dans la presse
sans les dire que non donc si on pouvait
voilà avoir cette confirmation là et
concernant l'article 23 donc on en a
longuement débattu hier moi j'étais
tendance à dire que le diable se nichent
dans les détails j'ai trois questions
assez précises qu'est-ce que l'on entend
par territoire Soudan c'est est-ce que
ces territoires est-ce que c'est les
zones Zac et zip au titre de l'ARS
est-ce qu'elles sont figées au moment où
intéresse donne en fait cette
cartographie qui un mois ou trois mois
après ou un an après peut être
complètement obsolète puisqu'on sait que
la majorité des médecins ont plus de 60
ans est-ce qu'il serait pas nécessaire
d'ajouter dans ces territoires souples
dans le la deuxième question c'est
effectivement vous dites prioritairement
enfin il est écrit prioritairement
territoire soudain ce que ça veut dire
prioritairement et est-ce que quand on
dit prioritairement dans les territoires
soudains s'il faudrait pas plutôt y
ajouter en fait des territoires où on y
trouve des exercices coordonnés enfin
des dynamiques de santé ou des projets
ou les ou effectivement ces jeunes
médecins pourraient s'y trouver enfin
autre chose qu'un territoire soudant
parce que derrière territoire soudain
c'est vous en avez visité plein c'est
pas toujours le désert non plus faut pas
exagérer ces stigmatisant et en plus
c'est pas toujours voilà c'est pas
toujours dramatique et enfin toujours
sur cet article 23 vous mettez enfin il
est écrit donc supervision qu'est-ce que
la supervision qu'est-ce qu'on parle
bien de mettre de universitaire et
auquel cas comment on va faire pour en
avoir un nombre suffisant pour que cet
article 23 puisse être appliqué dans de
bonnes conditions
merci alors moi j'avais avant de passer
la parole une question de Olivier
Hainaut qui a du partir qui demandait
s'il transfert de charge de branches
familles vers la branche santé était une
mesure conjoncturelle
ou durable
et moi j'avais une question sur le ria
channel
référentiel des actes innovants ornement
créatures
le PLFSS propose une réforme de série à
chaîne
mais pour autant il n'y a pas de voie de
financement nouvelle donc comment ça va
se passer
et la deuxième question
c'était comment la procédure permettra
la gestion plus dynamique de la prise en
charge
que l'étude d'impact
merci pour pour ces questions d'un champ
très très large ça a été dit par un
président tout ne relève pas du PLFSS
mais je vais essayer de répondre à
toutes les questions
concernant les médecins retraités
effectivement nous portons l'exonération
de la cotisation retraite pour les
médecins cumulant pour la retraite ça a
fait ça a montré son efficacité pendant
la crise covid et c'est un moyen pour
maintenir nos médecins dans les
territoires donc c'est tout à fait dans
ce dans ce cadre là
vous êtes revenu sur alors la quatrième
année il y a eu plusieurs questions
autour de la quatrième année je vais
essayer de globaliser un petit peu tout
ça
cette quatrième année de formation des
étudiants en médecine qui choisissent la
spécialité de médecine générale est une
quatrième année qui je le rappelle mais
vous le savez très bien et ça a été
discuté hier a été réclamé par les
étudiants eux-mêmes dans le cadre d'une
amélioration de leur formation et moi
que j'ai rencontré il y a six mois il
cherchait à être mieux formé déjà être
formé à gérer un cabinet médical parce
qu'en particulier dans le cas
d'exercices coordonnées ou d'exercices
pluriprofessionnels il faut apprendre à
gérer ce n'était pas appris et puis ils
avaient des lacunes d'après eux de
de formation en gynécologie obstétrique
et en pédiatrie qui sont en plus des
spécialités pour lesquelles nous avons
beaucoup de difficultés ça permet ça me
permet d'ailleurs de rappeler que
l'exercice de médecine générale est un
exercice exigeant parce que c'est un
exercice qui est
j'allais dire polymorphe mais qui
s'intéresse à l'ensemble du champ de la
médecine et j'en profite pour rappeler
que bien entendu dans les parcours de
santé et dans les parcours de soins le
rôle du médecin traitant généraliste et
primordial et il coordonne les prises en
charge quand il y en a un mais je
reviendrai un peu plus tard là-dessus et
sur les 6 millions de nos concitoyens
qui n'ont pas de médecins traitant cette
quatrième année est une année de docteur
junior à l'instar des autres spécialités
des 43 autres spécialités qui ont tous
une année de consolidation de
professionnalisation qui est une année
docteur junior il y avait pendant
lesquels les jeunes professionnels sont
en responsabilité et assurent des actes
d'ailleurs pour accéder à cette
quatrième année quelle qu'elle soit il
faut être Thésée c'est quelque chose qui
est important parce que les jeunes en
médecine générale retardent leur thèse
ce qui retarde d'autant leur
installation là ils devront être aisés
pour pouvoir prolonger leurs études ce
qui est un poids très positif c'est une
année d'étude avec un maître de stage
universitaire qui est supervise nous
avons actuellement 13000 mètres de stage
universitaire nous en avons 14000
l'année prochaine le fait de déclencher
cette quatrième année à partir de la
rentrée 2023 pour CDES fera que nous
avons en plus du temps pour recruter des
maîtres de stage supplémentaires
probablement des réflexions autour de
tout ça mais c'est précisément l'enjeu
de la mission que nous avons nommée avec
Sylvie Retailleau la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
bien sûr de quatre professionnels
reconnus indiscutable dont une jeune
médecin et qui doivent justement nous
faire des propositions sur
la réindgénie j'aime pas trop ce terme
mais de l'ensemble de ce desest de
médecine générale en 4 ans comme le
propose comme le propose ce projet de
loi
concernant
l'incitation la priorisation dans les
zones soudances là aussi c'est tout
l'enjeu de cette mission qui doit nous
faire des propositions je me permets
juste
d'alerter sur le point de la
rémunération de ces docteurs junior
effectivement ces docteurs Junior sont
rémunérés 2500 euros plus les gardes etc
2500 euros brut
ça concerne toutes les spécialités au
jour d'aujourd'hui
voilà je vais juste préciser cela
peut-être faut-il discuter mais la
mission nous le dira d'un financement
différent mais en tout cas bien avoir en
tête que ça ça concerne toutes les
spécialités
concernant oui pardon je voudrais juste
revenir sur les médecins de PMI puisque
j'ai pas été complet dans mon
information et en me confirme que les
médecins de PMI ont été revalorisés dans
le cadre de la Conférence des métiers de
février 2022
9000 médecins auteur de 45 millions
d'euros mais je transmets à
Jean-Christophe combe bien sûr qui est à
l'écoute je transmets l'ensemble de vos
remarques
concernant concernant concernant ensuite
on avait le Ségur alors le Ségur
juste pour rappeler sur le volet
investissement du Ségur
c'est 50% de plus que les deux derniers
plans hôpital
2007 et 2018 les 2012 pardon additionné
donc c'est un investissement de 9
milliards d'euros c'est plus que tout ce
qu'on a jamais fait en termes
d'investissement sur l'hôpital c'est 9
milliards d'euros se répartissent en 6,5
milliards pour transformer l'offre de
soins 1,5 milliards pour
l'investissement courant et puis une
réserve de 1 milliard d'euros qui avait
été mise de côté alors l'inflation bien
entendu il est nécessaire de regarder
comment l'inflation pèse sur le coût des
projets vous avez entièrement raison par
rapport à cela c'est pour ça que
l'administration est en train mon
administration est en train de de
travailler sur une méthode qui est
partagée avec l'ensemble des fédérations
pour une analyse par famille d'achat de
la structure des coûts de revient et des
indices d'évolution des prix
correspondants l'inflation n'a pas la
même incidence sur les matières
premières sur l'énergie sur les
transports donc on est en train de
regarder de façon extrêmement précise
juste petite
ajout 738 millions d'euros c'est ce qui
a été mis pour faire face aux effets un
peu inédits de l'inflation dans la dame
2022 donc déjà pour pour compenser mais
nous sommes nous sommes particulièrement
attentifs à cette cet effet de
l'inflation sur les investissements
Ségur vous l'avez dit vous avez parlé de
votre département sur la région
Normandie c'est 850 millions d'euros
investissements Ségur et par exemple sur
le CHU de Caen c'est 400 millions
d'euros pour la reconstruction du CHU de
Caen je pourrais vous donner d'autres
exemples comme Bayeux Lisieux ou le CH
de la Côte Fleurie
alors
les oui les alors les oubliés du Ségur
qui est le terme maintenant qui est qui
est aussi mis tout le temps alors je
suis désolé de préciser que ça ne
concerne plus l'hôpital puisque au
niveau de l'hôpital il n'y a pas
d'oublier de Ségure tout le monde a été
pris en compte dans le cas de la
revalorisation Ségure je précise bien ça
concerne le champ médico-social et
encore pour une partie très limitée qui
sont essentiellement les personnels
administratifs c'est un enjeu que
Jean-Christophe conduit de façon
extrêmement précise et qu'il aura
également à traiter dans le cadre de du
CNR autonomie et grand âge qu'il a mis
en place en tout cas pour les hôpitaux
il n'y a plus de questions le concernant
[Musique]
les IPA en psychiatrie et s'entraimental
se développe il faut encore qu'on en
forme encore plus parce qu'elles ont un
rôle important à jouer dans ce cadre là
et c'est un point effectivement de
vigilance majeure vous l'avez compris
maintenant j'ai toujours l'habitude de
dire et je continuerai malheureusement à
le dire que nous devons faire avec les
troupes que nous avons aujourd'hui et ça
rentre aussi dans le cadre des
réflexions qui ont été portées sur le
transfert des le transfert des
compétences et le partage des
compétences
concernant la biologie la biologie
médicale la biologie médicale est un
acte indispensable puisque 60 à 70% des
diagnostics médicaux sont faits sont
précisés grâce à la biologie médicale
c'est pour autant un secteur en très
forte augmentation de chiffre d'affaires
donc il tient compte de toutes leurs
frais par ailleurs très forte
augmentation c'est de l'ordre de 23%
je rappelle quand même que effectivement
pendant le covid ça a été dit tout a été
pris en charge à 100%. donc il est
logique comme je le disais qu'il
participe de façon équilibrée en
fonction de ce chiffre d'affaires qui
est augmenté de façon importante aux
mesures d'économiques globale en ce qui
concerne l'innovation plusieurs mesures
justement sont en place et sans discuter
avec les biologistes pour favoriser
l'innovation tout comme la sécurisation
des petits laboratoires malheureusement
il en reste plus beaucoup et c'est bien
l'objet de la question de nos travaux
avec les biologistes sur l'avenir de
cette filière qui est de plus en plus
rachetée par des grands groupes avec
probablement des avantages mais
probablement aussi des inconvénients
qu'il faut prendre en compte en ce qui
concerne les surcoutres-mères ils sont
bien entendu pris en compte et vous le
savez que j'ai un oeil particulièrement
attentif sur les sur les outre-mer
puisqu'on est dans ces mesures
d'économie sur les bios similaires
le séminaire c'est pas un médicament
générique c'est pas c'est pas tout à
fait comparable nous avons des
expérimentations en cours pour voir un
petit peu ce que l'on peut faire de
façon précise là-dessus
l'intuition de c'est une piste de
travail qui est tout à fait pertinente
et que nous sommes en train de suivre
mais pour laquelle nous n'avons pas de
d'aboutissement ou de conclusion
aujourd'hui des cures thermales ça fait
des années que ça dure des années que ça
dure à chaque période
je pensais pas que c'était très facile
c'est pas si évident que ça sur ces
problématiques des bio similaires avec
un équilibre là aussi à trouver chaque
fois qu'on parle de qu'on parle de
médicaments le thermalisme le
thermalisme est quelque chose
d'important pour de nombreux territoires
actuellement nous avons trouvé une forme
une forme d'équilibre
remboursement des frais de transport
mais sous condition de ressources assez
strictes et puis les cures qui sont
prises en charge sont pris en charge
pour des pathologies qui sont
précisément définies je pense par
exemple à la rhumatologie ou à la
rééducation fonctionnelle et je rappelle
quand même que sur des médecins qui font
ces prescriptions donc dans le cadre
d'acte bien bien identifié
l'article 22 ce n'est pas un
conditionnement sélectif très clairement
l'article 22 c'est ça fait partie de
vous l'avez compris de ma stratégie un
petit peu globale qui est de faire
confiance au territoire de considérer
que les problèmes sont sur les
territoires mais des solutions aussi et
en particulier en ce qui concerne la
permanence des soins qu'évoquait un
sénateur ni non cette permanence des
soins a été supprimés je fais le pari
d'une responsabilité collective à
l'échelle des territoires pourquoi je
fais ce pari parce que j'en ai discuté
avec avec les professionnels et avec les
syndicats de médecins et des syndicats
d'infirmiers pourquoi nous parlons de
permanence des soins sur les différentes
professions de santé parce que cet été
nous avons pu voir l'efficacité de
certaines mesures en particulier de
téléconsultation aidé avec une
infirmière des mesures également ou des
infirmières étaient à disposition la
nuit des EHPAD pour assurer la
couverture infirmière de ces EHPAD des
infirmières libéral donc effectivement
cette
partage de la permanence des soins se
partagent de cette pénibilité concerne
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
d'un territoire et c'est tout l'enjeu du
CNR santé de les laisser trouver des
solutions qui seront adaptées à leur
territoire
en ce qui concerne la formation au plus
près des territoires oui bien sûr on
sait que ça fonctionne que ça fonctionne
mieux
j'aurais l'occasion de reparler dans
vous de la construction des parcours
d'excellence avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale pour repérer les
jeunes puisque la meilleure chance qu'un
jeune s'installe à jeune médecin
s'installe dans un territoire dissoudant
c'est qu'il soit issu de ce territoire
c'en est 7 sur 10 donc il faut favoriser
probablement l'accès à ces études faire
passer le plafond de verre et j'ai un
certain nombre d'idées par rapport à ça
de développer je pense une autre fois
auprès de vous des études médicales sont
passées de 7 à 10 ans pour un médecin
généraliste oui la médecine générale est
devenue une spécialité
c'était une volonté c'était nécessaire
je ne pense pas que ce soit pertinent de
diminuer les cycles les deux premiers
cycles des études médicales d'autant que
nous entrons dans une réforme de ces
deux cycles qui est mise en place on me
dit souvent que les l'enseignement par
simulation permettrait diminuer les
études de médecine puisque on fait des
gestes plus vite je ne pense pas je
pense que ces études et sa durée
d'études si peut-être on a du gain un
petit peu de temps faudrait peut-être en
profiter pour rendre pour redonner son
côté humaniste à la médecine et pas
uniquement un côté technique
sur
la pénurie médicale je pense qu'on en a
on en a parlé
sur les complémentaires alors quelle
place les organismes complémentaires
dans notre financement de notre système
de santé depuis plusieurs années la part
des organismes complémentaires diminue
la part de la sécurité sociale augmente
essentiellement par l'apparition des
pathologies chroniques et des ALD donc
nous sommes en discussion avec eux
justement pour voir quelle Paris peuvent
prendre et en particulier dans le cadre
de la prévention
prévention de l'obésité oui on a parlé
de la prévention bon le développement du
nutri score
le chèque alimentaire pour maintenir le
pouvoir d'achat bien entendu mais
surtout dans l'axe de prévention et
j'aurais l'occasion d'en reparler devant
vous insistez sur la notion du sport
santé pourquoi le sport santé parce que
c'est la chose qui est la plus efficace
et la plus rapidement efficace en termes
de prévention si vous montez les marches
j'allais le courage de monter les 7
marches du ministère plutôt que de
prendre l'ascenseur les 7 étages pardon
plutôt que de prendre l'ascenseur parce
que cette marche j'arrive encore même
pour venir au deuxième étage chez vous
je pense que je me sentirai peut-être
mieux quoi que je me sente bien dans les
semaines qui viennent en tout cas c'est
quelque chose qui qui fait voir la
prévention sont bons côtés c'est un des
axes de la prévention arrêté d'être une
d'avoir une prévention culpabilisante et
puis profiter de l'occasion
extraordinaire qu'à notre pays
d'organiser deux très grands événements
sportifs la Coupe du monde de rugby
l'année prochaine et les Jeux Olympiques
l'année d'après pour se servir de ces
éléments
non justement mais si je peux me
permettre je pense que tous les tous les
1ers janvier vous avez tous comme moi la
volonté de refaire du sport d'arrêter de
fumer de faire plein de trucs et le 2
janvier on arrête mais là je pense que
notre pays va être un formidable terrain
de sport pendant les deux ans qui
viennent et tout le monde va vouloir
faire du sport ou d'exercice physique
donc je compte me servir de cela pour
amener le côté prévention
des assistants médicaux augmentaient oui
je me suis engagé dans le cadre du
discours du CNR santé pour passer à 10
000 assistants médicaux rapidement en
tout cas avant la fin du quinquennat
parce que un assistant médical pour un
médecin c'est 10% de clientèle en plus
donc c'est un moyen essentiel pour pour
augmenter cette capacité il faut
redonner du temps de de soins aux
soignants il faut redonner du temps
médical au Médecin concernant les padus
effectivement nous avons 2400 pas durs
alors il y en a un petit peu moins
puisque 1300 vont pouvoir être pris à la
fin d'année avec 70 commissions
qualification le problème n'était pas
que de la DGOS et de
du ministère c'était aussi des problèmes
des spécialistes des conseils de l'ordre
puisque ces commissions doivent réunir
aussi les spécialistes de la spécialité
concernées et nous allons repousser au
30 avril l'échéance qui est normalement
au 31 décembre pour permettre d'épurer
ces 1100 dossiers qui resteront en début
d'année ça concerne bien sûr le stock
vous le savez absolument pas les
nouveaux médecins qui arrivent qui ont
une procédure qui est différente le DMP
évolue vers mon Espace Santé la
promotion de mon Espace Santé continue
va s'accélérer et puis il sentait
mentale je vois qu'on en a déjà parlé je
pense à peu près avoir fait le tournant
il y avait le
herihn
bon le but bien sûr c'est d'accélérer
l'évolution de cette liste d'actes
innovants certains sont dans le
référentiel liste bougez pas nous avons
la vocation à soutenir bien sûr
l'innovation pour les actes de biologie
d'un apath ça fait partie justement des
discussions que nous avons avec avec les
biologistes
voilà je crois que j'ai à peu près fait
le tour des questions